شكرا للزميله فاطمه فهد صباح الخير
مشاهدينا تواصلوا العربيه معكم لليوم 11
على التوالي تغطيه الازمه السودانيه ليله
البارحه وافق طرف الصراع الجيش والدعم
السريع على الدخول في هدره اقترحتها
السعوديه والولايات المتحده لمده اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه وسط ترحيب من القوه الموقعه
على الاتفاق الايطالي الهدنه الجديده امام
تحدي اخر يضع قاده الجيش والدعم السريع
امام ضغط دولي خصوصا مع بدء عمليات اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب نحو مطار وميناء
بورتسودان سياسيا ادانت الخارجيه
السودانيه ما اسمته بنهج الدعم السريع
فاستهداف السفراء والدبلوماسي كما اكدت
على التزام الدوله بالهدنه وحرصها على
حمايه المدنيين
[موسيقى]
هذا وكان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
اعلن وقفه اطلاق النار بين الطرفين بدءا
من منتصف ليل الاثنين الى الثلاثاء بتوقيت
الخرطوم موضحا ان الهدنه ستسري في جميع
انحاء السودان
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع اعلن الموافقه على تنفيذ وقف اطلاق
نار على مستوى البلاد يستمر لمده 72 ساعه
بناء على وساطه سعوديه امريكيه وذلك من
اجل فتح ممرات انسانيه وتسهيل حركه
المواطنين والمقيمين وتمكينهم من قضاء
احتياجاتهم والوصول الى المستشفيات
والمناطق الامنه واجلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
من جانبه يدعى امينو عام مجلس التعاون
الخليجي جاسم البديوي طرفي النزاع في
السودان الى سرعه المضي قدما تجاه وقف
العمليات العسكريه والتحلي باقصى درجات
ضبط النفس وتجنب التصعيد وتغليب مصلحه
الشعب السوداني وضمان امنه واستقراره
والحفاظ على مكتسباته ومقدراته والعوده
الى الاتفاق الايطالي الهادف للوصول الى
اعلان سياسي
من اوستن ينضموا الينا الاكاديمي والباحثه
السياسيه الشفيع محمد احمد سيد الشفيع
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه على شاشه
العربيه الوساطه السعوديه الامريكيه دخلت
حيز التنفيذ منذ منتصف ليله البارحه حتى
الان
الاطراف هل يمكن القول بانها التزمت ام
غير ذلك برايك
هو قطعا غير ذلك اخي الفاضل قبل ان يجف
مداد هذه الدعوه الى الهدنه قد تمها الان
الان خبر عاجل قبل قليل طائرات الجيش
السوداني تحلق في كل سماء الخرطوم خبر
عاجل قبل قليل اطلاق نار وضرب في سجن
بورسودان الواضح انه يعني ليس هنالك اتجاه
لاي من الطرفين الى المضيق قدما في اي
هدنه او حتى وقف اطلاق النار من اجل يعني
الاجواء الى تسويه سياسيه او حتى تفاوض
على اي اتفاقيه ما بين الطرفين اخي الفاضل
لا احد لا مجال للحديث عن الهدنه في الوقت
الحالي لماذا لا يوجد هناك مجال الحديث عن
الهدنه في الوقت الحالي كل الاطراف دائما
عندما يتم اعلان هدنه حتى هدنه البارحه
اعلنت بانها ستلتزم بهذه الهدنه لكن
الاستجابه يعني تبدو ليست طويله وبعد ذلك
يتم خرق هذه الهدن لماذا يتم خرق شفيع
برايك واقع الواقع طبيعه الصراع نفسه يعطي
الصراع هي التي هي السبب الرئيسي في عدم
الالتزام بهذه هذا هو صراع ذات طبيعه
عسكريه ما بين الطرفين عسكري رسمي جيش
وطني
اسرع العسكري لا يحل الا عسكريا اخي
الفاضل ليس هنالك مجال لتسويه سياسي ما
بين الطرفين عسكريين احد تعقيدات هذا
الصراع الان النمو صراع ما بين جيشين
نظامي
ومليشاوي طيب
هناك من يقول بان السبب وراء يعني عدم
حدوث اختراق في هذه
الهدن بان هناك طرف ثالث مندس بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع يريد التخريب اي هدنه
انسانيه او يتم اعلانها بواسطه
الامريكيه السعوديه ليله البارحه هل ترى
او تعتقد بان هذا صحيح وفقا لما يجري على
الارض
وهو قطعا هنالك مستفيدين من هذا الصراع
وهما بالتحديد فضول النظام السابق هذا
يعني اما الجانب الرئيسي في هذا الصراع
ليس هنالك مجال
لتسويه ما بين الطرفين هذا الصراع كل طرف
يحاول جاهدا الى القضاء على الطرف الاخر
قطعا هنالك اطراف مستفيده من هذه الصراع
تستثمر في هذا الصراع لكن هذه عامل من
العوامل وليس العامل الوحيد هنالك اعوام
مداخله متشابكه بتقود الصراع الان في
السودان
نيه الجيش السوداني في القضاء على هذه
المليشه وانا نظريا ومن حيث المبدا اقول
انه من مصلحه الشعب السوداني ومن مصلحه
الدوله السودانيه ان ينتهي هذا الصراع
بتفكيك هذه المليشه ونعود الى جيش وطني
واحد مؤسسه عسكري سودانيه واحده على
علاتها نحن نعرف ان الجيش السوداني به
كثير من العلات وبه كثير والاخفاقات وهو
مختطف ومخترق من بعض فضول النظام السابق
مفهوم جدا هذا الحديث لكن يا سيدي الفاضل
مهما كان السوات الجيش السوداني ليس هنالك
عاقل يقبل ان ان يرى هذا الجيش ينهار امام
مليشيا
والشاهد الان الصراع هذا ينتهي بخروج هذه
المليشه من المشهد ثم بعد ذلك يعاد ترتيب
الدوله السودانيه وفق مؤسسات معروفه معترض
بها لها شرعيه لها انضباط في تنفيذ
اهدافها الحقيقيه اضرنا ما اطر بالدوله
السودانيه اكثر من المؤسسه العسكريه
السودانيه المؤسسه العسكريه السودانيه
كانت على الدوام تترك دورها الاساسي في
حمايه حدود السودان وتتوجه الى الحكم
هل هل من السهل ان تخرج قوات الدعم السريع
من المشهد السوداني بهذه البساطه التي
تتحدث عنها انجاز التعبير
فعاليه لهذا الشيء وان تكلفه سوف تكون
عاليه جدا والان نحن شايف انت ترى وتسمع
التكلفه العاليه في المدنيين
والدمار الحله بالخرطوم من الواضح ان
تكلفه ستكون عاليه جدا والواظف ان المهمه
ليست نزهه ليست من السهوله التي تصورها
بعض فضول النظام السابق الان نحن امام
اليوم الحادي عشر وما زالت الرؤيه لم تتضح
بعد سمعنا منذ اليوم الثاني ان هذه الامور
سوف تحسم خالي 72 ساعه والان المساله قد
طالت وتطاولت وتطول الواضح انك تستطيع ان
تبدا الحرب لكن لك لا تستطيع ان تنهيها
لكن اذا كنا نتحدث عن جيش نظامي عن قوات
مسلحه تملك مركبات عسكريه تملك ايضا طيران
ومن امامها قوات الدعم السريع لا تملك ذات
القدره العسكريه او حتى القدره البشريه
هنا لماذا تاخر الحسم
اخر الحسم بطبيعه حرب المدن
اكبر اشكالات هذه الحرب انها في العاصمه
في الخرطوم وانت تعرف ان حرب المدن من
اصعب الحروب والجيش السوداني بتاريخ
الطويل في الحروب الاهليه الا انه لم يدخل
في حروب مدن الخرطوم على امتداد حروب
السودان في دارفور او حتى في اخواننا في
جنوب السودان لم تتعرض الخرطوم لمثل هذا
المحك ولمثل هذا الامتحان العسير طبعا
السيده ساعود اليك لكن دعني فقط اذكر بهذه
الاخبار العاجله اذا سمحت الدعم السريع
يقول بان الجيش قصف مواقعنا قرب القصر
الجمهوري في انتهاك
للهدنه وايضا قال كذلك بين القصف العشوائي
للجيش السوداني يهدد حياه المدنيين
والرعايه الاجانب في الخرطوم اذا الدعم
السريع يقول بان الجيش قصف مواقعنا قرب
القصر الجمهوري في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم للهدنه وقالت بان القصف العشوائي
ايضا للجيش
السوداني يهدد حياه المدنيين والرعايه
الاجانب كذلك في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم هذا ابرز ما جاء اذا في هذا
البيان لقوات الدعم السريع والتي قالت
بانها او اتهمت الجيش السوداني بانه
استهدف مواقع لها قربه القصر الجمهوري
بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم هذا البيان
اذا للجيش او لقوات الدعم السريع والتي
تهمت فيها الجيش السوداني بانه هو من
انتهك هذه الهدنه مصادر العربيه ايضا تقول
بان سلطات سجن بورتسودان تحتوي احتجاجات
لسجناء يطالبون
بالخروج من سجن بورت سودان اعود اليك سيدي
الشفيع مره اخرى لاسال كنت تتحدث عن حرب
المدن اهل الجيش السوداني اقل قدره من
قوات الدعم السريع في حرب المدن لذلك هنا
الكفه غير متساويه بين الطرفين
اقل قدره فانه خيارات محدوده جدا لمراعاه
حمايه المدنيين ولماعات لمراعاه حمايه
المؤسسات المدنيه هذه هي ما يحد قدرات
الجيش السوداني في حسم المعركه العسكريه
من اجل تغليل التكلفه البشريه والاقتصاديه
ابقى معي سيد الشافعي ساعود اليك مره اخرى
في ثنايا هذه التغطيه اذا مشاهدينا
منذ اربعه ايام تلعب المملكه العربيه
السعوديه دورا انسانيا رائدا في اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب من مناطق القتال في
السودان السعوديه خصصت قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده لاستقبال رعايه دول قبل
ترتيب نقلهم الى بلدانهم في وقت لاحق
[موسيقى]
هذا هو اعلن وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان في تغريده على تويتر
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه ستتواصل مع
الاشقاء في السودان لتامين ممرات امنه
لاجلاء رعايه الدول الصديقه والشقيقه كما
اكد الامير فيصل بن فرحان مواصله المملكه
عمليه اجلاء رعايه الدول التي تقدمت بطلب
مساعده مواطنيها ونقلهم لاماكن امنه
حاليا اول شيء هو الشكر الجزيل للقياده
والشعب السعودي على الجهود اللي بدلت في
سبيل اجلال رعايه الليبيين 104 شخص طبعا
انطلقنا من يوم الخميس صباحا الى يوم
الجمعه رحله طويله لمده 25 ساعه الى مدينه
بورسودان وبعد ذلك بقينا ثلاثه ايام حتى
تمت عمليه
الجلاع نشكر المملكه العربيه السعوديه على
كل قدموا لنا طلعونا وجابونا وقعدونا
الطريق كنسل السومه وما قصروا معنا بشيء
ما في خدمه طلبناها ما كانوا موفرينها
فالحمد لله تم الاتفاق مع السفاره
اللبنانيه والسفيره اللبنانيه عملت
اتصالاتها مع السعوديه مشكورين كثير على
كل شيء قدمتوه من جهد نحن بنشكركم كثير من
قلبنا
وبشانه عمليه الاجلاء من بورتسودان نحو
جده قال القنصل التركي ان التنسيق مع
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه كان عاليا وان
السعوديه لم تجلب الرعايه الاتراك من
السودان فقط بل ستستضيفهم ايضا في جده
يعني
لقد تم التنسيق مع وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه التي ابلغتنا بموعد وصول هذه
السفينه وعلى متنها مواطنون اتراك التنسيق
كان عاليه جدا والاهتمام كان كبيرا
سنستقبل مواطنين هنا بحراره نحن نعلم ان
السعوديه لم تحضر عيان من السودان فقط بل
ستستضيفهم في جده نتوجه بالشكر لخادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
شكرا لكم
اما بشان عمليه جلاء الرعايه الليبيين على
متن السفينه السعوديه من بورتسودان فقال
القنصل الليبي في جده عبد الرزاق المنفي
عدد الرعايه الليبيين بلغ 104 مواطنين شكر
المملكه على تقديم كافه الخدمات
والمساعدات لاعاده الرعايه الليبيين الى
وطنهم عدد الرعايه الليبيين 104 مواطن
ومواطنه جلهم من الجاريه الليبيه
الدبلوماسيه وموظفين بالبنوك والطلبه
وطبعا الظروف ظروف صراع وحرب تم اجلاؤهم
الى منطقه بورسودان وبالتنسيق مع
الوزاره الخارجيه السعوديه عن طريق السفير
السعودي
وبتوجيهات من خادم الحرمين الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز حفظه الله ولي عهد الامين
صراحه قدمه كافه الخدمات والمساعده لجميع
الجاليات وليس للجائزه الليبيه فقط ونحن
الان بانتظارهم بناء جده تنسيق الى عودتهم
ان شاء الله لارض الوطن
بدوره توجه القنصل الامريكي في جده فارس
اسعد بالشكر للمملكه على مساعدتها في
عمليه اجلاء الرعايه الامريكيين من
السودان
الرئيس بايدن ميونخ من يوم السبت نقول انه
عم نحب نشكر المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وشركائنا واصحابنا هون بالسعوديين
لمساعدتهم
للامركان الذين على هذه السفينه اليوم
احنا كثير متشكرين كانت التنسيق كتير كتير
كتير عام كويس كانت كثير قوي واحنا كتير
متشكرين للحكومه وايضا للشعب السعودي كانت
تعرف انه امانه امانه
امانه المواطنين الامريكيين هي من اعلى
اوليويات
لحكومتنا خصوصا الامريكان من برا ولايه
المتحده
ومعنا من معبر ايرجين على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان احمد
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه كيف ترصد حتى
هذه اللحظه عمليات الاجلاء عبر هذا المعبر
والصوره ايضا من حولك
نعمل فعل هناك استمرار في التدفق نايف في
عمليات الاجلاء من هذا المنفذ البري الذي
نشط كثيرا خلال الايام الاخيره لنقل
الكثير سواء من المصريين او من السودانيين
او من بعض الابناء الرعايه الدول الاخرى
وربما ملفات نظري بانم اغلب هذه الدول
ربما هي الدول الاوروبيه يعني رايت الكثير
من ابناء الجاليه الاوكرانيه في السودان
وايضا من جورجيا كان هناك استقبال لعدد من
المبعوثين من السفارات سفير جورجيا كان
هنا منذ ساعات للاشراف على خروج
الذين خرجوا او ابناء الجاليه الجورجيه
الذين خرجوا من السودان ربما من خلال ما
تحدثنا فيه مع بعض المواطنين كما ترى من
حولي الذين يركبون ويستعدون لركوب
الحافلات بعد
مرورهم من هذا المعبر انطلاقا الى اكثر من
مكان في مصر غالبا سيكون التوجه المركز
الرئيسي الى مدينه اسوان التي حوالي خمسه
ساعات من الان بالسياره
للانتقال لمطار اسوان لربما ان يكون هناك
رحلات جويه سواء الى بلدانهم او الى
القاهره او بعض السودانيين الذين سيمكسون
خلال الفتره المقبله في اسوان او بعض
المراكز الاخرى مثل كومبو هناك الكثير او
او ابو سنبل هناك الكثير من المراكز في
هذه المنطقه التي تشهد تجمعات لابناء
الجاليه السودانيه ربما خلال حديثي نايف
مع بعض السودانيين الذين انتقلوا الى هنا
اكدوا بان فكره الوصول الى هنا كانت صعبه
للغايه لان المسافه تقريبا ما بين الخرطوم
وهذا المركز حوالي 900 كيلو متر وربما هو
هذا ما عرضهم للكثير من المخاطر والتردد
في ان يكون هناك يعني اللجوء الى المنفذ
البري وعلى الرغم من هذا كان هناك تدفق
للالاف هناك العشرات من الحافلات التي
تدخل يوميا هناك تسهيلات وعمل على قدم
الوثائق من المؤسسات المصريه المختلفه
التي حاولت ان توفر ممرات امنه مع مع
الفريق السوداني المتابع هناك لتامين وصول
هذه الوفود الى المنفذ ولكن كما ذكرت لك
هناك ايضا تسهيلات فيما يتعلق باستقبالهم
هنا هناك ايضا تدقيق في الكثير من
المواطنين الذين يدخلون تحديدا من
المصريين او من الجنسيات الاخرى تتذكر في
انه في الفتره ما بعد 2013 كان هناك رصد
لمحاولات هروب الكثير من العناصر
الاخوانيه الى السودان عبر المنافذ البريه
ومن ثم هناك حرص مصري بان هذه التسهيلات
والمعامله الطيبه ايضا ستكون متزامنه معها
ايضا عمليه تدقيق لمنع تسلل اي عناصر
ارهابيه للدخول الى مصر استغلالا للاحداث
التي جرت في السودان او التي تجري في
السودان خلال الايام الاخيره ممتاز
يعني انت ذكرت بان عمليه الاجلاء او
غالبيه هذه الحافلات ايضا تتوجه الى مطار
اسوان اريد اولا معرفه المسافه ما بين
المعبر الى المطار هل هناك رحلات او ربما
زياده في الرحلات المتجهه من اسوان ايضا
كذلك الى العاصمه القاهره ان كانت لديك
معلومات
بالفعل يعني هناك اكثر من طريقه للوصول
يعني للتحرك من هذا المركز الحافلات تتجه
اغلبها الى اسوان ابناء الجاليه السودانيه
الذين يعني لديهم اقارب هنا او اصدقاء هنا
يتجهون الى اسوان لقضاء فتره الايام
المقبله بحسب ما تحدثت معهم في اسوان عن
طريق هذه المراكز وهذه العائلات ربما لرصد
اذا نجاح هذه الهدنه وامكانيه العوده مره
اخرى كثير ممن تحدثت معهم قالوا باننا
ربما جئنا بملابسنا فقط لم ناتي باي شيء
هربا من القذائف والموت وبالتالي هناك من
سيستمرون هنا في اسوان لمده عدد من الايام
لمراقبه الموقف في السودان وبالتالي ربما
سيكون هناك القرار هذه الحافلات كما ذكرت
لك تتجه من هنا الى اسوان في حوالي خمسه
ساعات هذا بالنسبه الى المصريين العائدين
هنا ايضا الى اسوان اذا كانوا يعيشون في
مدن في الصعيد بالقرب من اسوان سيكون هناك
مركز كركر الذي مركز حافلات يتوجهون به
الى عدد من المدن القريبه من اسوان في
الصعيد او حافلات اخرى تتجه الى مدنهم
اغلب الجاليات الاجنبيه او الرعايه
الاجانب سينتقلون بطائرات من اسوان الى
القاهره استعدادا للعوده لميدانهم خلال
الفتره الماضيه نحن نتحدث يعني كل هذا
فيما يتعلق بالاجلاء البري هناك ايضا جهود
تمت في مساله انجلاء طيران تقوم بها
طائرات عسكريه تم عوده طائرتين في الامس
تقل مجموعه من الطلاب هناك ارض ايضا كما
ذكرت لك خشيه من ان فكره ان هناك من
يتضررون او يتردد ان تكون هناك رحله طويله
بريه من الخرطوم الى هذا المنفذ اشكرك
جزيلا شكر على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
من معبر اركين على الحدود المصريه
السوداني مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان نذكر
مشاهدينا ايضا ومستمعينا كذلك بهذا الخبر
العاجل الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
يؤكد اصابه جندي فرنسي خلال عمليات
الاجلاء من السودان اذا الرئيس الفرنسي
مانويل ماكرون يؤكد اصابه جندي فرنسي خلال
عمليات الاجلاء من السودان كذلك ايضا فيما
يخص فرنسا كان قد اعلن الرئيس الفرنسي
مانويل ماكرون بان فرنسا اجلت 538 شخصا من
السودان بينهم
فرنسيين هذه ايضا الاخبار والانباء تتعلق
بفرنسا اذا الذي اكد رئيسها ايمانويل
ماكرون اصابه جندي فرنسي في عمليات
الاجلاء اذا من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
التي تشهد اشتباكات واسعه بين الجيش
السوداني وق وات الدعم السريع منذ اكثر من
احد عشر يوما نبقى فيما يخص عمليات
الاجلاب
ومن الميناء الشمالي بمدينه بوتسودان شرق
السودان على ساحل البحر الاحمر ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي نزار مرحبا بك
معي في هذه التغطيه
تابعنا الصوره مع الزميل احمد قبل قليل من
اركينا الصوره هل تختلف لديك في
بورتسودان كيف كيف هي الان وهل لا زالت
ايضا اعداد من تم اجلائهم من السودان
تتزايد عبر ميناء
نعم الصوره هي ذات الصوره وذات المشهد لكن
ذلك عبر البر وهنا عبر البحر هذه الصوره
من خلفي مباشره هذه احدى القطع البحريه
الهنديه وصلت في الساعات الاولى من صباح
هذا اليوم وعلى متنها الان نحو 292 الى
جانب طاقم هذه الباخره او القدعه العسكريه
الهنديه التي وصلت اليوم الى الميناء
الشمالي في بورسودان
الرعايه الهنود اكملوا الاجراءات دخلوا
مباشره قبل نصف ساعه الى هذه السفينه التي
ستبحر بعد دقائق من الان
وستستقر في ميناء جده على الجانب الاخر من
البحر وبعدها مباشره تشرع الجهات المسؤوله
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وفي
الممثلين للسفاره الهنديه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في توفيق وفي استكمال
اجراءات كل الذين تم اجلائهم من السودان
حتى يتسنى لهم العبور الى دوله الهند سواء
كان عبر البحر او عبر الطيران التابع
للخطوط الجويه الهنديه عندما تغادر هذه
الباخره سترسوا مباشره في ذات المكان
باخره اخرى ستجلي نحو 500 من رعايه دوله
الهند الذين يوجدوا الان داخل مدينه
بورسودان وصلوا قبل يومين هم الان ايضا
اكملوا كافه الاجراءات المتعلقه بمغادره
السودان نحن نتحدث الان وقد وصلت قبل ربع
ساعه من الان قطعه بحريه فرنسيه تحمل
اعلام عدد من الدول الاوروبيه هذه القطعه
ستعمل على اجلاء موظفين التابعين للامم
المتحده ولمنظمه الغذاء العالميه يقدر
عددهم باكثر من الف موظف الى جانب ممثلين
لبعاسات دبلوماسيه
سيصلون بعد قليل الى مي بورسودان لتكمله
اجراءاتهم سنحاول ان نعبر بالكاميرا
لمعرفه او لاضاءه حول هذه القطعه البحريه
التي وصلت قبل قليل الى ميناء بورسودان
وستتبعها عدد من القطع البحريه اتباعا الى
شرق السودان في عمليه اجلاء يبدو انها
الاكبر خلال السنوات الماضيه لاجلاء الاف
الرعايه الذين اتخذوا مسارات متعدده سواء
كان عبر البحر هنا في شرق السودان او عبر
البر منه منها من الخرطوم الى مصر او الى
اثيوبيا او الى الولايات القريبه من
العاصمه الخرطوم وهي ولايات امنه عدد من
رعايه دول وصلوا الى مدينه بورسودان
ينتظرون استكمال الاجراءات السفر سيغادرون
هذه المدينه عبر البحر وعبر المطار الذي
اعد ويشرف على هذا الامر اطقم من الجيش
ومن الشرطه ومن هيئه الموانئ البحريه اذا
هذه صور ينقلها لنا الزميل نزار بقداوي
لمواكبه العربيه عمليات الاجلال الرعايه
والدبلوماسيين الاجانب من ميناء بورتسودان
قبل قليل تابعنا فرقاطه وقطعه بحريه
عسكريه اذا او عفوا قطعه بحريه هنديه وصلت
الى ميناء بورت سودان هذه الفرنسيه ايضا
تحمل علام عدد من الدول الاوروبيه ايضا
كذلك كما نشاهد امامنا على الشاشه نزار
تحددته قبل قليل عن
اجراءات للاجلافي ميناء بورتسودان هل
تختلف عن الاجراءات الروتينيه
الاجراءات الروتينيه المعروفه طبعا
السفر المواطنين او حتى الاجانب من
الميناء املا في هذه المره هناك اجراءات
مختلفه
يعني حسب مشاهداتي وحسب متابعاتي حسب
المراقبه لواقع هذه العمليه التي بدات منذ
الحادي والعشرين وتستمر حتى اليوم وحتى
الساعات المقبله
تتم عمليه الاجراءات على
مستويين المستوى الاول حصر الذين وصلوا او
سيصلون الى شرق السودان تحديدا الى ميناء
بورسودان والذين
تم حصرهم مباشره تتعامل معهم اداره
الجوازات والجنسيه التابعه لوزاره
الداخليه السودانيه باشراف من قبل الجيش
السوداني يتم حصر الاعداد ويتم مراجعه
الاوراق الثبوتيه وجوازات السفر وتوفيق
اوضاع من ليس له اوراق ولم يتسنى له اخذ
الاوراق الثبوتيه نتيجه للاضطرابات
الامنيه التي شهدتها العاصمه الخرطوم وعدد
من الولايات حسب المتابعات والملاحظات
والاستفسار من القائمين على هذا الامر
الاحظ بان العمليه تمضي بسرعه وبسلاسه
وتناغم بين البعثات الدبلوماسيه وبين
وزاره الداخليه وبين الجيش وبين الامن
البحري وبين الاجهزه الامنيه التي تعمل
على مدار الساعه لتامين عمليه الاجلاء
ايضا من الملاحظات التي لاحظناها بان عدد
من الدول العربيه والاوروبيه بدلا ان تنسق
عمليه الاجلاء مفردها هذه الدول يبدو انها
توافقت واتفقت على ان تقوم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بالاشراف على اجلاء عدد
من رعايه الدول وهم في حدود 10 دول هذه
الدول نسقت مع سفاره المملكه العربيه في
السودان حتى
تساهم المملكه العربيه بحكم الجوار وبحكم
الامكانيات في اجلاء الرعايه وبالفعل
غادرت مساء امس باخره وقد وصلت الى ميناء
جده
وستغادر ايضا اطقم بحريه وممثلين لسفارات
ايضا باشراف وترتيب وتنسيق بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وعدد من الدول العربيه
والاسيويه في عمليه لا يبدو انها ستستمر
وسفير المملكه يوم الامس في حديثه الخاص
لقناه العربيه قال بانهم يتلقون طلبات على
استمرار من عدد من الدول لاجلاء رعاياها
من السودان الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لكن وبعدها مباشره لكن
الرعايه من السعوديه الى مختلف الدول ربما
من يشاهد الان يسال انه لماذا المملكه
العربيه السعوديه يعني لماذا هذه الدول
اتفقت مع السعوديه ان تقوم هي باجراء هذه
الاعداد ان تكون حتى السفاره السعوديه في
الخرطوم هي من تستضيف كل من يرغب بالخروج
من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطمان تصبح مقصدا
لكل
مواطني
هذه الدول الموجودين في السودان نزار
يعني انت تدرك وتعلم تماما الوضعيه
الاستراتيجيه ومكانه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في المنطقه وتاثيرات السعوديه
على المشهد عموما دوليا واقليميا هذه من
ناحيه من الناحيه الثانيه بانه عندما
اعلنت السلطات السودانيه اغلاق المجال
الجوي حتى الثلاثين من هذا الشهر الخيارات
اصبحت ضئيله واصبحت محدوده اما برا عبر
اثيوبيا في معبر القلابات على حدود
السودان مع اثيوبيا او عبر مصر في معبر
ارجين الشمالا واما عبر البحر عبر البحر
الخيار الافضل والمثالي والذي يعني تتوفر
فيه كل سبل السلامه والامكانيات وتقديم
الدعم وتقديم الدعم اللوجستي وكل ما يلزم
هو عبر المملكه العربيه السعوديه والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه يبدو انها وحسب ايضا
افادات السفير السعودي هنا في السودان
تقوم الان بدورها هي على اتم الاستعداد
لتقديم كل العون وكل الاسهام وكل المساعده
للسودان مختلف الدول التي تريد ان تساهم
في عمليه الاجلاء ايضا العلاقات التي
تتمتع بها المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
المحيط الداخلي هنا في السودان والعلاقات
الممتده لسفاره المملكه العربيه السعوديه
هي الان تمضي بفاعليه في عدد من المسارات
السياسيه السعوديه الان هي احد الاطلوع
المهمه في الرباعيه الدوليه التي تمثل
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا والسعوديه
ودوله الامارات هذه الوضعيه المهمه وهذه
وهذه الاساسيات التي ترتكز عليها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وثقه الرعايه ومواطني
عدد من الدول في قدره المملكه العربيه
السعوديه على تقديم الدعم والسند في الوقت
اللازم وانجاح هذه العمليه بكل يسر وبكل
ثلاثه وهو مشجع هذه الدول على ان تتجه
مباشره ودون اي تردد لتنسق مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في عمليه الاجلاء الشكر
من الميناء الشمالي بمدينه بورسودان شرق
السودان مراسل العربيه نزار شكرا جزيلا لك
نزار
اذا تستمر بميناء بورتسودان شرقي السودان
لليوم الخامس على التوالي عملياته اجلال
مئات من رعايه الدول العربيه والاسيويه
والاوروبيه عبر الجوي والبحر حيث تابعت
العربيه مراحل اجراءات اجلاء مئات الرعايه
من دوله الهند فيما ينتظر نحو الفين من
رعايه الدول الممثل البعثات الدبلوماسيه
وموظفي الامم المتحده تكمله اجراءات
اجلائهم من السودان عبر الميناء خلال
الساعات المقبله
هذا هو الميناء الشمالي بمدينه بورسودان
بولايه البحر الاحمر بشرق السودان هنا
تستمر عمليه الاجلاء لمئات من رعايه الدول
العربيه والاوروبيه والاسيويه التي بدات
من الخرطوم العاصمه برا الى شرق السودان
ومنها عبر البحر الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبعدها يغادرون الى دولهم عمليه
الاجلاء تمضي تحت اشراف كامل من قبل الجيش
السوداني عبر مسارين بحري وجوي وكانت
العديد من الدول العربيه والاسيويه
والاوروبيه قد شرعت في التنسيق مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في الترتيب لاجلاء
رعاياها خلال الساعات الماضيه
في هذه المرحله من مراحل عمليه الاجلاء
التي بدات هنا في شرق السودان يتم الوصول
الى هذه المرحله وهي مرحله الاستوثاق من
الاوراق الثبوتيه ومن الجوازات هنا تقوم
الشرطه السودانيه ممثله في اداره الجوازات
والهجره بالتعرف على كافه الاوراق
الثبوتيه وجوازات السفر تمهيدا
لنقلهم عبر الباخره الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ومنها الى بقيه دولهم هنا
292 من رعايه دوله الهند بالسودان اكملوا
اجراءات مغادرتهم واجلائهم من مدينه
بورسودان الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومنها الى دولتهم فيما ينتظر اخرون
استكمال اجراءاتهم لمغادره البلاد خلال
الساعات المقبله نزار البغداوي لقناتي
العربيه والحدث الميناء الشمالي مدينه
بورسودان شرقي السودان
[موسيقى]
واجهت مصر واعضاء السفارتها في الخرطوم
بعدم التحرك الا لحالات الضروره كما شددت
الاجراءات الامنيه حول سفارتها بالخرطوم
واعضائها منذ ليله البارحه وذكرت مصادر
للعربيه ان هناك تنسيقا مع جانب السوداني
لفتح تحقيق في مقتل مساعد الملحق الاداري
بعد ان طلبت القاهره مزيدا من التوضيحات
حول ملابسات الحادث وقالت المصادر ايضا
انه سيتم نقل جثمان مساعد الملحق الاداري
على احدى الطائرات المصريه لدفنه في مصر
وفقا للمصادر ايضا فقد تم تجديد الاجراءات
الامنيه حول السفاره المصريه بالتنسيق بين
الجانبين المصري والسوداني للتامين عناصر
واعضاء السفاره المصريه وتحركاتها خلال
الساعه المقبله بشكل اكبر
هذا وقد اعربت السعوديه عن تعازيها لمصر
بوفاه مساعد الملحق الاداري المصري بسفاره
القاهره في الخرطوم وجددت وزاره الخارجيه
دعوه المملكه الى وقف العمليات وتجنب
التصعيد والعوده الى الاتفاق الايطالي
الهادفي للوصول الى اعلان سياسي يحقق
الامنياء والاستقرار
كما نشاهد في الاخبار العاجله اسفل الشاشه
مجلس التعاون الخليجي بجهود السعوديه
لاجلاء الرعايه من السودان كذلك ايضا مجلس
التعاون
الخليجي
اشاد قبل ان يشير طبعا بالجهود دعا طرفي
النزاع في السودان الى وقف العمليات
العسكريه والى ضبط النفس كذلك
هذه الصور مباشره كما نشاهد واياكم الان
من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم والتي دخلت
الازمه فيها يومها الحاديه عشر كما نشاهد
امامنا الان على شاشه العربيه
الصوره من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم التي
تشهد عمليات اجلاء واسعه
لاعضاء البعثات الدبلوماسيه وكذلك ايضا
مواطني الدول
الاجنبيه الموجوده طبعا في السودان
قبل قليل كان الدعم السريع قد اعلن بان
الجيش خرق الهدنه التي تمت الموافقه عليها
من الطرفين بواسطه سعوديه امريكيه وقال
بان الجيش قصف مواقعنا الحديث على لسان
الدعم السريع قرب القصر الجمهوري في
انتهاك للهدن
جانبها اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع بالسودان
مشاهدينا في بيان انها ستتعاون مع مصر
لكشف الحقائق حول مقتل مساعد الملحق
الاداري بالسفاره المصريه في الخرطوم
اضافت قوه الدعم السريع في بيان ان يدا
الغدر التي امتدت للفقيد ارادت ان تعبث
بالعلاقات الاخويه بين الشعبين الشقيقين
وكانت الخارجيه المصريه قد اعلنت مقتل
مساعد الملحق الاداري محمد الغراوي خلال
توجهه من منزله الى مقر السفاره لمتابعه
اجراءات الاجلاء الخاصه بالمواطنين
المصريين في السودان
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحفي والاعلامي
السوداني ابو بكر السمان السيد ابو بكر
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه المباشره على
شاشه العربيه السؤال اليوم عن ما بعد
استهداف المساعده الملحق العسكري في مصر
لا اسال هنا عن مصر فقط اسال ايضا عن كل
البعثات الدبلوماسيه التي لا زالت موجوده
في العاصمه الخرطوم كيف يمكن تامينها الا
يمكن ان تتكرر ذات الحادثه مع بعثات
الدبلوماسيه اخرى
نعم حقيقه يعني استهداف
الملحقه او مساعد الملحقه الاداري في
الخرطوم في هذا الدرس وخاصه نحن منذ يوم
امس واليوم نتابع الهدنه وكل الناس كانت
مترقبه بشكل حصيف وقريب جدا وكنا محضرين
للحد البعيد او نحاول ان نرى عن الامور
تمشي بالوتيره التي خطط لها لكن مقتل
مساعده الملحقه الاداري في
السفاره هنا في السودان يبدو لي انه مؤشر
سالب بدرجه كبيره جدا مباشره التصريحات
بدات تظهر من هنا وهنا خاصه فيما يلي
الدعم السريع في مخاطبته للجانب المصري
كنت معكم منذ الامس في ساعات الصباح
الاولى وقلت ان نجاح هذه السنه مرتبط
بالتصريحات وحزرنا كثيرا من هذه التصريحات
من الجانبين التصريحات وكانما الحرب اولها
كلامه ونحن في
والرعايه الاخرين الذين هم يتواجدون الان
داخل السودان اذا نحن كلنا نراقب ونتفق
على ان مساله ضبط النفس هي مساله مهمه جدا
يمكن ان تحل بدرجه كبيره مساله الهدن
ويمكن ان تسلمنا من كثير من المنزلقات
التي يمكن ان تحدث من وقت لاخر نتمنى ان
لا تتكرر مثل هذه الحوادث المؤسفه
والمؤلمه طبعا وان تسلم كل الرعايه
الموجودين الان هم في السودان مساله ضبط
النفس كيف يمكن ضبطها
انا ارى ان مساله ضبط النفس تتضح بصوره
جليه من التصريحات التصريحات هذه خطيره
جدا تدل على مكان النفس وتدل على ما يمكن
ان يحدث الساعات القادمه كلما كانت
التصريحات هادئه كل او حتى عدم التصريح
عدم التصريح في حد ذاته هو يهيا الاجواء
ويعيد الامور الى نصابها ويؤشر بدرجه
كبيره جدا الى ان هناك نوع من الالتزام من
الجانبين لكن التصريحات الكثيره
والخروقات من حدوث مثل هذه الاحداث مقتل
الملحقه الاداري هي مساله تشير بدرجه
كبيره جدا على ان هناك ربما عدم جديه في
مساله الهدنه وبالتالي عدم جديه فيها
الارواح والاشخاص الذين سلامه هؤلاء
الاشخاص الذين يتواجدون الان في السودان
كل هذه المؤشرات تشير وتؤكد بان السلامه
للجميع في هذه المرحله وبالذات الجاليه
الاجنبيه المتواجده في هي مساله مهمه جدا
لان السودان في هذه اللحظه هو له مشاكل
داخليه عميقه جدا نحن في غنى عن اي مسائل
اخرى او حتى مشاكل مع اي طرف او ايجار في
الحدود السودانيه في اتجاهاتها المختلفه
اذا كل هذه التداعيات تشير بدرجه كبيره
جدا الى ان كل من له مصلحه في
ان تستقر هذه الاوضاع وكل السياسيين يجب
ان يسعوا وبدرجه كبيره جدا الى مؤشر الى
الجانبين بضروره ضبط النفس وعدم اصدار اي
تصريحات او القيام باي اعمال يمكن ان تؤثر
على الجاليات الاخرى وعلى المواطنه
السوداني دعني هنا اسال عن دور الايجاد عن
دور الاتحاد الافريقي ايضا كذلك في هذه
المساله في ربما تطوير الامور اكثر حتى
ترقى الى هدنه مؤقته على الاقل لمده
24 ساعه بين الطرفين وانت تستمر بلا
خروقات كما يعني تابعنا بشكل مستمر خلال
الفتره الماضيه هل هذا ممكن
اما يعني كما قلت سلامه واستق السودان
يؤثر بشكل كبير خاصه مثلا دوله يعني دوله
معروفه بانها فيها الكثير من الانقلابات
دوله مثل افريقيا الوسطى ومثل ليبيا وايضا
مصر الشقيقه ويعني هذه الظلال يعني يتضح
بما لا يدعم مجال انه استقرار الاوضاع في
السودان هو في هذه اللحظه منوط بقوات
القوات الشعب المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريعه
الهدوء محاوله الجلوس والتفاوض مع
السياسيين والخيرين من كل دول العالم
وايضا المنظمات العالميه وفي امريكا وفي
اوروبا هذه
المنظمات وتلك الجمعيات العالميه لابد ان
تتدخل وبصوره جديه ولابد ان تكون
التصريحات بالنسبه للمسؤولين العالميين
بلغه هي اكثر جديه واكثر قوه مخاطبين كل
الفريقين الدعم السريع وقوات الشعب
المسلحه لانه كما قلنا الاوضاع في السودان
كلما
توترا كلما فشلت كثير جدا من النقاط التي
يمكن ان تكون بدايه لنهايه هذه الحرب
بالامس ونحن نعلق على الهدنه من المفترض
تفائلنا كثيرا يعني بانه ربما اذا استمر
الوضع واستقر وكان هناك انسياب للحركه
الطبيعيه والتزام كل من الجانبين طريقه
وفتحت الممرات الامنه واستطاعت الفرق
الطبيه ان تؤدي دورها كان ذلك يمكن ان
يكون البدايه لنهايه حقيقيه لهذه الحرب او
على الاقل وفي اسوء الفروض ويفتح المجال
لجلوس الاطراف السياسيه وبالتالي هدوء
الاحوال العسكريه والامنيه للجانبين فان
التسارع هذه الوتيره بالتاكيد هو سيلقي
بظلال لن تكون جيده في كل الاحوال ممتاز
يعني اعذرني على المقاطعه انا اريد دائما
ان اتوقف لقراءه الاخبار العاجله حتى يعني
نكون دائما في الحدث بشكل ادق مع مشاهدينا
ومع مستمعينا ايضا كذلك مكتب الشؤون
الانسانيه الان بالامم المتحده يقول بانه
اضطر لتقليص
وجوده بمناطق الاشتباكات في السودان اذا
مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه بالامم المتحده
يقول بانه اضطر لتقليص وجوده بمناطق
الاشتباكات في السودان وهو السؤال ايضا
كذلك السيد ابو بكر عن تقليص وجود هذه
المكاتب الانسانيه التابعه للامم المتحده
للمنظمات ايضا حتى الانسانيه
والاغاثيه لاي مدى سينعكس على الحياه
الاجتماعيه والمدنيه ايضا كذلك على المدني
بصوره اكبر في السودان خلال الفتره
القريبه القادمه
والمؤسف ايضا في هذا الموضوع انه يعني
السودان كان يرسل الجالياته ويرسل بعثاته
الدبلوماسيه ويوصلها واقم التعليميه لهذه
الدول العربيه الان هو السودان اصبح يعني
ينظر اليه من باعتبار انه لا يمكن ان يعود
الى تلك النقطه الاولى احنا كنا نعلم
الدول ونعلم الشعوب الان الناس لا تستطيع
حتى ان تتاكد من اننا حققنا هدنه بسيطه مع
بعضنا البعض
والفشل في في مساله اداره الموقف السياسي
هو يؤشر بدرجه كبيره جدا لانهيار الدوله
كل ما نخشاه ان ينهار الوضع بالكامل في
السودان وان لا نستطيع حتى ادخال المواد
الاساسيه الطبيه او حتى الغذائيه البسيطه
فهذه هذا مؤشر بالتاكيد لن تكون له قراءات
واضحه وايجابيه على المستوى السياسي في
المنطقه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الخ رطوم
انضم الينا الصحفي والاعلاميه السوداني
ابو بكر السماني شكرا جزيلا لك اذا
مشاهدينا السودان هي النقطه الاكثر تماسا
مع الدول الافريقيه السودان دوله جوار
لسبع دول نتعرف على هذه الدول المحاديه
والممرات البحريه كذا البريه ايضا للسودان
جمهوريه السودان محاطه بعده دول من ثلاثه
اتجاهات تحدها سبعه دول شمالا وغربا
وجنوبا مع تعدد المعابر البريه والممرات
المائيه لها الجاره الشماليه مصر تتشارك
مع السودان بحدود طولها
1276 كيلومترا في منطقه صحراويه بشكل عام
وبها معبران رئيسيه هما اشكيت وارجين
ليبيا على الجهه الاخرى تربطها بالسودان
حدود تمتد ل 3002 كيلومترا في بيئه تتنوع
تضاريسها ما بين صحراء وجبال وسهول يوجد
معبر واحد بين الدولتين هو العوينات قرب
المثلث الحدودي بين الدولتين ومصر
الى الغرب من السودان شريط حدودي مع تشاد
طوله
1403 كيلومترات ومعبر رئيسي يربط بين
مدينتي الجنينه في دارفور وادري في تشاد
اكثر حدود للسودان تربطها بجمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى وتقل عن 200 كيلومتر معبر
وحيد هو امدافوج بالقرب من هذه الحدود نجد
اطول حدود للسودان وهي مع دوله جنوب
السودان طولها 1900 كيلو متر وبها عشره
معابر حدوديه متفق عليها بين الدولتين الا
انه لم يتم افتتاح كل هذه المعابر في جنوب
شرق البلاد تشترك السودان مع اثيوبيا
بسبعمائه واربعه واربعين مترا من الحدود
مع معبر رئيسي هو الفشجه سابع الدول
المحاذيه للسودان اريتريا مع حدود طولها
605 كم ومعبر وحيد هو طوكر
وفي الجهه الشرقيه من السودان وممراتها
البحريه على البحر الاحمر فهي تضم مينا
اين رئيسيين هما ميناء بورتسودان وسواكن
حسن غولد العربيه
بعد ساعات من سريان هدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام
بوساطه سعوديه امريكيه افاد مراسل العربيه
ان ادويه لاسلحه الثقيله عاد ليسمع في ام
درمان وفي محيط القصر بالخرطوم بحسب شهود
عيان هناك ايضا تحليق طيران وضرب مدفعيه
وسماع واصوات اشتباكات
متقطعه باسلحه خفيفه ايضا
الى اوستن اعود والى الاكاديميه والبحث
الشفيع مرحبا بك معي قبل ان اختم ايضا معك
قبل قليل او ان اطلب منك البقاء كنا نتحدث
عن
استفاده فلول النظام السابق وبانها الطرف
المستفيده الاكبر مما يحدث اليوم في
السودان نريد ان تبسط لنا هذه المساله كيف
استطاع النظام السابق وفول النظام السابق
في الاستفاده مما يحدث اليوم في السودان
وفي الواقع عندما سقط يعني البشير في 2018
في ثوره ديسمبر المجيده سقط راس النظام
فقط لكن ظل نظام الحركه الاسلاميه ونظام
المؤتمر الوطني ممسك بتلاليب الدوله
السودانيه في كافه مؤسساتها هؤلاء يعني
على مدار 30 عاما ظلوا
يجنون الامتيازات بطريقه غير شيعيه من كل
موارد الدوله السودانيه
مصالحهم فساد كبير في 90% من مؤسسه الدوله
السودانيه فيها حالات فساد موثقه وانت
تعلم عندما قامت لجنه ازاله التمكين كشفت
عدد مهول من عمليات الفساد التي تمت خلال
30 عاما طوال حكم البشر هؤلاء مصيرهم
السجون
[موسيقى]
لكن بين طرفي الصراع يعني من المستفيد من
من هروب او او اطلاق صراحه هؤلاء
يعني فلول للنظام السابق كما سميتهم انت
ايضا قبل قليل من السجون من السجن كوبر ان
صحت هذه المعلومه من المستفيد هنا الجيش
الدعم السريع ام هناك طرف ثالث مستفيد
ايضا من المساله البرهان
الامر حاضن الرئيسي التي حول هي من فلول
النظام السابق ومن الاسلاميين الذين ما
زالوا في المؤسسه العسكريه وفي المؤسسات
الامنيه هو المستفيد رقم واحد وحتى نسمع
يعني نسمع اغاويل تتحدث عن ان هذه الحرب
هي حرب فلول النظام السابق وليس حرب الجيش
السودان هم من دقوا طبولها الواقع يقول
الان اخي الفاضل اننا امام مشهد على درجه
عاليه من التعقيد لكن برغم تعقيدات المشهد
لا بد ان يكون هنالك باب للامل من ان تحل
الامور طيب في سياق يخلق تسويه سياسيه
ويحافظ على الدوله السودانيه ويمنع
السودانيه من الانزلاق الى اي يعني واضح
الات يعني تفتح الباب لكل الاحتمالات
الشكر من اوستن الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي
الشفيع محمد احمد شكرا جزيلا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات